[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com things are truly genuinely
honestly not going well for Donald
Trump's personal attorney Michael Cohen
you probably remember that the FBI
raided his office and his hotel room and
I believe his condo as well not long ago
and law enforcement collected a ton of
documents during that raid a couple of
months ago and the government has turned
over nearly 4 million seized documents
so far - Michael Cohen's attorneys to
figure out is there privileged
information in any of these 3.7 million
documents and some of the documents that
the FBI found had been shredded and the
latest news is that the FBI is now
piecing together the shredded documents
and of course they're not doing this by
hand there are now computer programs
that can do this and at this point it
has gotten so insane that Trump's
attorneys attorneys are working around
the clock reviewing the four million
documents that the FBI has given them
and not only are there unshredded
documents and shredded documents which
we'll talk about in a second there are
also hard drives and thumb drives and
many many Blackberry phones so it's an
endless sort of treasure trove of
possible evidence of crimes and
originally Cohen's team was given until
June 15th to go over the nearly 4
million documents his lawyers are
understandably saying we need like way
way way more time to do this so I want
to focus in for now since it could be a
while until we actually learn more about
the contents of these documents about
the meaning of these shredded documents
and I understand you hear shredded
documents and many people think you
shred documents to hide stuff not
necessarily right I mean attorneys do
shred documents regularly for non
sketchy reasons but yeah if I'm the FBI
I'm looking very very closely at the
document
that michael cohen has shredded and
former FBI analyst asha ranga tweeted
about this quote i've watched people
pieced together shredded documents it's
amazing this is not going to end well
for the defense and former prosecutor
renato Mariotti also on twitter saying
federal prosecutors are piecing together
page papers shredded by michael cohen
that is bad news for him and one of the
funniest things about all of this is
that most lawyers have moved to what's
called crosscut shredding like you might
remember sometimes seeing vertical strip
shred shredders right this is where you
run a page through it and it shreds a
document into these strips those are
easier to reconstruct with the software
that now is available but most lawyers
now have moved to crosscut crosscut not
crush crosscut shredders which read in
multiple directions according to stormy
Daniels attorney Michael avenatti Cohen
had the old strip shredders that he was
using a transcript from his interview
with CNN has Jake Tapper saying let me
ask you a question
federal prosecutors say they're putting
together papers that have been shredded
by Michael Cohen do you know anything
about those papers and Michael avenatti
responding yesterday from what I've
gathered Michael Cohen was so cheap he
didn't invest in a crosscut shredder
which would have made it impossible for
investigators at Quantico forensic
specialists at Quantico to refabricate
or reconstitute these documents
evidently he had a different type of
shredder so they're in the process of
going through it from what I heard in
court today if true it is truly stupid
Watergate and I don't think I have to
remind anybody that if indeed the
shredded documents were related to what
the FBI is looking into and the
shredding took place after Michael Cohen
knew that the FBI was looking into it
that's the possible crying a crime of
destruction of evidence so it is really
not looking good for Cohen right now
well I mean come on Michael Cohen can't
afford a crosscut shredder his three
clients right one is Sean Hannity who
apparently gave him ten bucks at a party
once and that's it and the other is
Donald Trump who never pays his legal
bills and remember Cohen had to pay for
the story me Daniels hush money so ya
can't afford that
apparently we can't expect him to get
that fancy shredder make Maga not make
America great again
my attorneys getting arrested one
possibility also make America great
again no it's making attorneys get
attorneys I like both as much better
yeah not good for michael cohen
indictment when i think probably pretty
soon let's talk about Jill Stein as most
of you know I've been saying that Jill
Stein's campaign stunk from the get-go
and every time I say it people get mad
people cancel memberships people send me
angry messages but you know that I don't
sugarcoat my views on the show if I'm
going to say something that will anger
people I'm okay with that as long as
it's what I actually believe and that
has been sort of the guiding principle
on the show the latest with Jill Stein
is that there seems to be something
really weird going on with those
millions of dollars that Jill Stein
raised to pay for a recount of the 2016
presidential election in some key swing
states and from the beginning I was
asking number one from a legal
standpoint can Jill Stein demand or
trigger a recount for elections that she
definitely didn't win in other words
does she have standing to request or
demand or force a recount in a state
where either Donald Trump or Hillary
Clinton won I don't know what the answer
was to that but it ended up being merely
academic because it never moved forward
and from day one it stunk to high heaven
that Jill Stein after appearing at an
event in Russia with Michael Flynn and
Vladimir Putin immediately dismissed the
possibility that Russia made any
attempts to influence the 2016 election
but immediately started raising millions
of dollars for these nebulous recounts
that it wasn't even clear whether she
could get started because of standing
issues but she raised seven million
dollars from people who wanted the
recounts in those few states it has been
about a year and a half the Stein
campaign has not filed an FEC report
since September of 2017 it's been almost
a year and the campaign said about a
month and a half ago that they have only
nine hundred and thirty two thousand
dollars in recount funds left where did
the other six million dollars go
how did Jill Stein and her campaign
spend six million dollars in 16 months
and why did they stop filing reports
about that spending and The Daily Beast
reached out to Jill Stein's attorney
jonathan Abadi who said well you know
the recount effort is continuing first
of all I want to know what specific
realistic recount efforts are underway
how is the money being spent for
furthering those recount efforts
Jill Stein's campaign spokesperson says
that there still could be a recount and
that the Stein campaign is also bringing
another challenge regarding inspecting
voting software that was used in some
states I'm having a very hard time
believing that any of this stuff is
actually going to happen and bigger
picture we need her campaign held
accountable for not reporting their
spending right the FEC has already
warned Jill Stein about about this there
has been a half a year of spending
unaccounted for that the FEC wrote to
her about in May and then of course this
goes fundamentally to jill Stein's
honesty or lack thereof her campaign
made the promise that any leftover money
the roughly 160 1,000 donors who donated
would get to decide how the money is
used not only has that not happened 6/7
of the money is gone six million of the
seven million dollars is gone without a
single recount and without actually
being accounted for and I'm not patting
myself on the back I and many others
warned people about donating Curt Eiken
Walled warned people about donating Jill
Stein has been refusing to cooperate
with the Russia investigation she has
not filed the appropriate reports about
the spending I'm not surprised at all by
this yeah I mean it's a little bit hard
to believe that they just took the money
and ran though because this was all done
in public right they were asking for a
recount money you know out in the public
square so that would be quite brazen to
do don't you think I mean it's not like
they're doing some underground secretive
thing where they're trying to come up
with some Ponzi scheme here we don't
know what they're doing right we don't
know what they're doing because six
million has been spent and they haven't
filed any spending reports
September and we don't know what's going
on with the recounts which they simply
claim are continuing it's almost the
next election right it's almost November
of 2018 now if you don't like the story
if you don't like me doing this story
don't tell me I'm a Democratic shill
because I'm not don't tell me I'm a
Russia bot and I don't mean that's
actually that I should clarify what I
mean by that that has a couple of
meanings right now I don't mean that
people are going accusing me of being a
Russian bot what I mean is a sort of
focus only on Russia and believe every
single story on critically about Russian
because I'm not tell me specifically
what I'm wrong about on the facts
regarding what Jill Stein said and what
Jill Stein and her campaign have or have
not done and then we can have a
conversation about that but don't just
riddle me with ad hominem x'
on social media because you don't like
the fact that i'm talking about this but
i do want to hear from you send me your
thoughts i'm on twitter at d pakman
quick break back after this the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new member of the day
is Amanda B and Amy Amanda thank you so
much for being a david pakman show
member and I also want to thank longtime
member David Bevers Dorf who's been
supporting the david pakman show since
2012 pat was in kindergarten back when
David Bevers Dorf became a david pakman
show member I was just learning to walk
luckily I was potty-trained by that time
yes otherwise it would be a very awkward
day for David Bevers dork to be a
longtime member of the day join Amanda
and David at join pakman.com 40% off
coupon code is available as vote soon 18
and it's a big big thing membership is a
big deal the world-famous bonus show is
available to you every day and you can
also get a lot of these same benefits
over on patreon by becoming a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show the
david pakman show subreddit has been
titillated and abuzz
ever since yesterday's Roseanne Barr
incident where she called me a bully on
social media just hours after getting
fired by ABC one of the discussions on
the subreddit is exactly that Rosanna
calls David Pakman a bully on Twitter
Roseanne you have now officially crossed
the line we'll just wait until the next
segment where I talk about what FoxNews
did with regard to my little spat with
Roseanne Barr on Twitter very exciting
yeah
if Rose Ann's first comment about
Valerie Jarrett didn't get her fired by
ABC this certainly would have yes apps
of calling me a bully on Twitter would
have been grounds for Bob Iger
immediately firing her also on the David
Pakman show subreddit this is from two
nights ago Sean Hannity is losing it
tonight this guy is insane talk about a
bunch of snowflakes yet when I saw this
I actually tuned in to Fox News because
I was so curious and this was in the
midst of the Roseanne Barr thing the
revelations about the michael cohen
shredded documents i mean just every
possible thing going completely wrong
Trump totally cocked by the North and
South Korean leaders and Hannity was
totally losing it and we know that
Hannity and Trump have a special
relationship of sorts and it was not a
good day in Hannity Ville two nights ago
even crazier that night you would say
because Hannity is losing it all the
time it was particularly unhinged yeah I
mean listen I guess I can't really judge
cuz I'm not normally watching Hannity
but from what I remember he seemed extra
wacky on on Tuesday night also from the
David Pakman show subreddit I would like
David to get more conservative talk show
hosts on the show he always seems to win
the argument and make them look
completely stupid I don't know that
that's how it goes I mean I do think
that a lot of our audience is
predisposed to see my side of a lot of
issues but I am I'm up for here's the
thing about doing the the thing where I
interview conservative talk show hosts
in general the audience doesn't I can't
say what the audience does or doesn't
like but the audience doesn't tend to be
that interested from a numbers
perspective in me interviewing other
political commentators right the things
that seem to do better our interviews
with actual newsmakers primary sources
on issues scientists professors experts
in fields when I do the interviews with
other pundit types or commentator types
it doesn't usually do that well with
some exception so that's why I we tend
not to book those types of guests but
I'm totally up for having more
conservative talk show hosts on if
people are interested in that yeah it's
kind of surprising in a way because
you'd think that if they have a big
audience their viewers would want to see
the exchange too if they tell their
audience that they're appearing on the
show which they might not what he does
they may they may not be doing that so
anyway something to think about I'm sort
of open to it and lastly from the David
Pakman show subreddit entitled David
tries to shame a busy scientist for not
clearing a schedule to talk to David for
free so that David can profit this is a
troll on our subreddit what they're
referring to is the other day Pat sent
an email out to Ben Goldacre who wrote a
book named bad science who I'm reading
the book and I'd like to interview him
and his publicist wrote back basically
saying he's too busy unless we give him
money and we've never paid any guests to
be on the show so I was not pleased with
that so I went on Twitter and I tweeted
him listen I'm really disappointed I'm
reading your book I think it's fantastic
and your publicist says you can only do
it if we pay you and he wrote back
genuinely seeming sort of surprised that
his publicist was saying that but still
not agreeing to come on for without
charging and the the subreddit user is
saying I'm entitled because I expect him
to appear for free it's not that I
expect him to appear for free it's that
you don't really pay for interview yet I
know either you say as a guest I want to
appear because I want to have the
conversation or I think that it'll sell
books or whatever or you say you're not
going to do it but the I'm really busy
unless you pay me thing is not something
that's very common from guests I don't
think it's about my entitlement if
anything it's about the entitlement of
that publicist to say unless you can pay
you're not we're not going to do it and
also I was thinking what is the amount
they would expect right we had a
conversation off air because if all they
want is a hundred bucks it's pretty
pathetic to even say I would only do it
if you give me a hundred bucks if they
want five grand
it's just laughable like how would
anyone think that paying Ben Goldacre
five grand to appear would be worth it
for anybody I was willing to empty my
piggy bank but you were convincing me
that nine dollars and sixty two cents
wasn't gonna cut it
no you changed my mind if 962 was what
it was going to take then it's pathetic
and that's not really an interview we
should be doing anyway so yeah I'm
really entitled for trying to bring good
guests to the audience what a terrible
person I am okay let's settle back down
david pakman.com slash reddit is where
you can participate in those discussions
ok listen so Fox News has reported on
Roseanne Bars response to me on Twitter
yesterday after her firing but has
removed all evidence that she was
actually responding to me so remind you
yesterday when Roseanne said that ambien
may have been responsible we can
actually go back to the beginning this
all started when Roseanne tweeted Muslim
Brotherhood and Planet of the Apes had a
baby equals Valerie Jarrett that got her
fired from ABC News and then she put out
there the idea that it was ambien that
was in some way responsible for these
tweets and when she did that I responded
to her and said on Twitter oh man this
is just the best Roseann is now
defending her tweets by saying ambien
made her racist and she responded
directly to me saying no I didn't I
blamed myself
stop lying yes I have had odd ambien
experiences on tweeting late at night
like many other people do I blame myself
okay it's just an explanation not an
excuse
okay bully so Fox News reported on that
tweet they removed the reference to her
tweeting too deep Hackman which is me
and they also removed that last thing
where she said okay bully because that
would make it sort of obvious that she's
responding to someone and here is how
Fox News reported on Roseanne Bars tweet
to me no evidence that I was involved in
this thing whatsoever
Roseanne then simultaneously thanked her
supporters for defending her and then
asked them not to stick up for her
quoting hey guys don't defend me it's
sweet of you to try but losing my show
is zero compared to being labeled a
racist over one tweet that I regret even
more and then when she blamed ambien man
Twitter took her to task on Roseanne
responded quoting no I didn't I blamed
myself
stop lying yes I have had odd ambien
experiences on tweeting late at night
like many other people do I blame myself
okay and the ellipses there which was
visible to people who are watching tells
the tale of what was removed which was
calling me a bully I don't really care
but it's yet again I mean just a month
or so ago when Stephen Colbert picked up
on the fact that Melania had liked our
tweet or a tweet about our story
questioning what's going on with her and
Donald Trump's relationship Stephen
Colbert also removing all references to
me and I know it's not all about me but
it's just funny that we keep getting
cooked by corporate media I think they
just don't want to get lost in the
details so it's not a direct insult it's
more of a missed opportunity I think I
think it's a missed opportunity is the
right way to say it I like how your
Twitter though and in your Twitter who
took her to task right I heard the
Twitter took her to task
they showed a response it was a response
to me right it would have been nice to
get a little mention but that sounded
like trace Gallagher reading those
tweets not expecting a shout-out from
trace Gallagher anytime soon on Fox News
let's talk about net neutrality I've
been covering not only the federal
government effort to restore net
neutrality the Senate vote to do it
which now goes to the house but also
some of the state-level efforts that
have been going on and one of those
state-level efforts is in California
which is a state bigger than many
countries when it comes to population
and also GDP the California or I guess
it wouldn't be GDP it would be state
production state productivity and the
California Senate yesterday voted to
approve a bill that would restore the
net neutrality provisions that were
repealed by the FCC in December it was
approved completely among Senate party
lines 23 Democrats all voted for net
neutrality in California 12 Republicans
did not and now it goes to the state
assembly and I'm hopeful that if the
right wants to live by states rights
they might also die by states rights and
what I mean by that is the FCC repeals
net neutrality federally 20 attorneys
general sue at the state level governors
look at using executive orders to
reinstate elements of net neutrality and
others look at using their state Senate
and legislatures to maybe put net
neutrality back in and the same could
apply in other areas right like gun
safety as long as you don't violate the
Second Amendment states can do more than
the federal government is doing on gun
safety business regulation minimum wage
basic income tests whatever else states
can do these things but of course only
some states can afford to usually blue
states that are better off economically
often subsidizing red states around the
country actually so back to net
neutrality in California this bill would
not only put back in place those
original net neutrality rules from 2015
under Barack Obama it would actually do
more and one of the things that the
California bill would do is block what
are called zero ratings zero rating
programs and what zero rating programs
are are when is piece a certain content
could be content
money from could be content they maybe
even own watching certain content
doesn't count towards your monthly data
cap and that is yet another way that an
isp can favor some content over other
content and if the bill ultimately
passes Internet service providers will
not be able to get government contracts
in California without sticking to the
rules that are passed and this is a
really important thing to understand
states can't enforce net neutrality
directly as of right now relates to
commerce law there is a lawsuit over
that but as of right now states can't
just generally enforce net neutrality
law what states can do is to set rules
for what ISPs that they work with have
to do and this relates to something
called the market participant doctrine
we don't have to get into the details of
that but the way that states can sort of
effectively enforce net neutrality is by
setting requirements that ISPs have to
meet in order to get contracts with the
state what this sort of means de-facto
is that since an ISP is not going to
have one set of rules for their state
customers and another set of rules for
all other customers in the state the
state and individual consumers basically
just become consumers and you've got the
same rules for everybody but what does
it possibly mean if the state laws start
being adopted in multiple states well
that's the idea right if you see
multiple states adopt laws that require
some version of net neutrality in order
to get state contracts you might see
ISPs just say you know what let's just
make this policy federally it is an
uphill battle it's a major one but it's
one that I think is worth fighting
because how important this issue is
right I've talked to you about the meta
issue of net neutrality and I'm going to
keep you posted about other states that
are working on similar bills right now
legislators in 29 states have introduced
more than 58 bills of dealing with net
neutrality in some way shape or form
this is a good thing this is a meta
issue and it's an issue that whatever
activism you want to be doing whether
it's on LGBT rights or education or
whatever else your ability to be
effective in that active
we'll be impacted by net neutrality and
that is why I am going to continue
talking discuss this with us on our
subreddit david patten.com slash our IDI
vit quick break back up the david pakman
show at david pakman.com welcome back to
the David Pakman show I'm joined today
by Ryan Cooper who's a national
correspondent at the week has a very
interesting piece out about the Roseanne
Barr fiasco which we've sort of been
pulled into a little bit she very very
angrily called me a bully on Twitter
Ryan just to give you a little bit of
context after I sort of jokingly poked
fun at the idea that ambien might have
made her racist or at least disinhibited
her enough that she would be willing to
tweet racist things but in in your piece
you talk about Roseanne in a sense as a
sort of martyr of a sort making herself
a martyr and some followers of hers
doing the same thing can you talk about
that a little bit what did you mean by
that
well I mean basically the first thing to
remember about Roseanne is that she
literally has like a severe mental
illness apparently multiple personality
disorder and has a sort of
characteristic a lot of paranoid
political views that tend to swing back
and forth very quickly from one extreme
to the other you know in 2012 she was a
Green Party she was trying to get the
Green Party nomination for president
right in 2009 she was calling Israel a
Nazi state and now she's a fanatical
Zionist and a fanatical trump supporter
and one of the characteristics of the
the just you know normal Trump
supporters is just a kind of more
moderate version of what Roseanne's
apparent inability to stop posting and
stop posting classic Trumpy stuff which
is racism against immigrants against
Muslims and Arabs and black people as
well so you know this is just like you
know what ABC wanted was to sort of cash
in on on some Trump pop political stuff
to just say like we're gonna have a
trump II show by Trump supporter where
the character is also a Trump supporter
and they got what they were asking for
and they show God great ratings at least
at first but then you know it turns out
that that comes with the actual Trump
beliefs one of which is violence racism
anybody having to do with the Obama
administration especially and so you
know he caught calling Valerie Jarrett a
you know of um ape is just what you're
going to get with that yeah man I think
that anybody who was sort of like
surprised by the comment was just not
paying attention to Roseanne for the
last many many years and I want to get
back to the mental illness component
it's in a second to talk about this from
ABC's perspective my analysis from day
one was that neither the reboot of the
series nor the firing of Roseanne has
any connection to any sort of moral or
ethical value judgment of the show nor
of anything that Roseanne did it's been
just business decisions all along the
reboot as you mentioned was out of this
idea that it could be great business to
do a show that seems to sort of be
sympathetic to the down-home Trump
supporting good old whatever of Middle
America and the firing also was what
they assessed to be the best business
decision at the time but to ascribe any
morality to it I think is wrong unless
you think otherwise no I don't I mean
certainly you can't perceive any of that
maybe there was some sort of buried
moral trigger and the
black hearts of ABC executives that was
finally dredged up by this last tweet
but you know they there was the audio of
them ABC executives in an advertising
meeting they were they were joking about
how Trump's her sorry
Roseanne's tweets were so incredibly
offensive and weird so yeah I think it
was it was a purely business decision
there was just a calculation of you know
ratings versus diluting the brand equity
or sparking a potential boycott from
liberals you know it's like at a certain
point you'd want to cut your losses but
yeah there was no morality here the
Mental Illness thing I mean the you
pointed out some of the the ideas that
Roseanne has has parroted retweeted over
the last many years it includes you know
CIA mind control conspiracy theory stuff
about George Soros involved in almost
every area of life that at some point
somebody has suggested and I think that
that's something that is either often
missed or sort of miscalculated when we
think about some of these incidents that
happen publicly I mean the the pattern
is this sort of paranoid delusions that
seem to have been an underlying theme of
a lot of the political conspiracies that
she subscribed to how should we as the
public account for the fact that whether
it's Roseanne or somebody else there do
sometimes seem to be significant mental
illness components to these implosions
that take place publicly I mean how
should the general public account for
that in our reaction you know that's a
really hard question it's you know I
mean the the the question of assigning
morale you know liability to someone who
may not be in full possession of you
know their faculties I feel like it's
it's kind of a case-by-case basis you
know because
you know there are lots and lots of
different kinds of mental illness people
are you know some of them are mild and
don't interfere with people's ability to
reason while others you knows can be
totally debilitating where people are
are not even you know coherent at all
this seems like kind of somewhere in the
middle you know I I it certainly to me
seems like there is an kind of an
uncomfortable element of exploitation in
this and that Roseanne you know she she
does
by all accounts have serious mental
illness that may not be being treated
properly and her wild antics get tons of
attention and ABC you know clearly knew
about that and was capitalizing on it
and you know what she may have needed
was not this kind of immense level of
celebrity and attention and more like
you know of some therapy and treatment
of some sort but on the other hand you
know I mean it doesn't I mean obviously
I don't know Roseanne personally I've
never met her or anything like that but
she doesn't seem like someone who is
completely senseless you know she can
still speak and she certainly seems to
have you know honestly held awful views
about you know black people and Arabs
and Muslims and and you know George
Soros so I don't know you know
ultimately I guess it would I would come
down and somewhere in the middle
thinking that you know Roseanne is not
without blame but it's it's a bit of an
exculpatory factor being unwell in that
way you've in addition to writing about
Roseanne and we're going to link to your
article about
you've also talked about the
intellectual darkweb so-called
intellectual darkweb a bit and this sort
of free speech warrior movement that is
out there and I think that that's
interesting in this story because there
is a group of people that like to or at
least first analyze stories through the
lens of the so called battle of ideas
which I have a hard time even saying
non-city really at this point or through
the lens of free speech and censorship
and I found it interesting that some of
the individuals who last week applauded
the decision of the National Football
League to say you now were not allowed
to sit or kneel or or not stand
basically during the national anthem if
you're gonna be on the field before a
football game and applauded that
decision are saying that the decision
now made by ABC to fire Roseanne is
somehow an impingement on her free
speech or censorship of comments that
she made outside of her employment
relationship with ABC or whatever
fundamentally aren't these just both
cases of private businesses making
decisions that they calculate are the
right business decisions for them and
that I guess let me couch the question
this way is there any way you can even
conceive of in which one might have a
different opinion of the NFL decision
and the ABC opinion are there any
material differences I would say it's a
very it's very similar in one sense in
that yes you know these are these are
private businesses I think that you
could make a you could make a tolerable
sort of constitutional argument that you
know this that the case of the NFL
players you know not then they're not
saying anything in you know any sort of
explicit way but just you know sort of
is this like passive demonstration music
is constitutionally protected speech in
a way that just like egregiously
offending
the you know your bosses is not but you
know yeah I mean it I think it goes to a
heart though of of the totally unserious
way that this so-called intellectual
dark web issue has been treated you know
you you have a bunch of people who you
know this Jordan Pederson and and Dave
Rubin and so forth who are being set up
you know as these like victims of
oppression but there's no real kind of
attempt to articulate the differences
you know and and systematically
investigate the issue of suppressed
speech which is absolutely rampant in
this country and usually it you know the
worst cases all usually involves stuff
like Palestinian BDS activists and so
forth
they've literally lots of attempts to
make that kind of speech illegal and not
just like people yell at you on Twitter
but yeah you know it it certainly you
know that this I think the Rosanne case
was particularly illustrative because
this would be a case where you could buy
the lights of the kind of intellectual
dark web people you know they ought to
have raised the exact same stink over
that as they have over you know other
instances of people being mean people
losing their jobs but in this case the
comment was so racist that there you
know there was just if it was you know
indefensible and I think it goes to the
heart of what these that this the Barry
Weiss and so forth are actually doing
which is constructing tendentious
definitional sort of fortresses around
their preferred positions and not any
sort of rigorous defense of free speech
as such yeah it seems that the free
speech component is one that is a tool
to use when useful given the
circumstances and not actually sort of a
true philosophical print
possible sort of to explore and the
depth that it probably should be
Ryan Cooper is a national correspondent
at the week we are going to link to some
of his recent articles Ryan great to
speak to you thanks for having me the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
not too long ago extreme neoconservative
Warhawk john bolton was hired by donald
trump to be his third national security
adviser of an administration that's
still not even 18 months old
you'll remember Trump's first national
security adviser was Michael Flint he's
been indicted Trump's second national
security adviser was HR McMaster he was
too much of a voice of reason to stay as
Donald Trump's national security adviser
so in comes John Bolton one of the
architects of the Iraq war which Trump
supposedly said was the biggest mistake
of the Bush administration but
nevertheless in comes John Bolton as
Trump's third national security adviser
and immediately after John Bolton's
hiring the United States is announcing
its pulling out of the Iran deal North
Korea blames Bolton in part for the
cancellation of the summit with Trump
which may or may not be back on I guess
we're not really sure at this point we
still have an interview scheduled to
take place from the summit even though
we don't know whether the summit is
actually going on but we'll talk about
that at another point and it's very very
clear that Bolton's sort of
neoconservative Warhawk ISM is
immediately having an impact in the
Trump White House and now the latest is
that John Bolton has hired a hate group
executive as his chief of staff fred
flight's has been hired to run the staff
of the national security council he's
been the senior vice president of Frank
Gaffney's center for security policy and
Dylan Williams from J Street tweeted
about this saying John Bolton has chosen
Fred flight's as the new National
Security Council chief of staff flights
is senior VP of Frank Gaffney center for
security policy a Southern Poverty Law
Center designated hate group that the
anti-defamation league condemns as quote
dedicated to advancement of myriad
conspiracy theories and anti-muslim
extremism this is really really really
bad Frank Gaffney is a complete
extremist lunatic who has actually had
contact with Trump he's one of these
conspiracy theorists many of the
conspiracy theorists are anti-muslim he
said for example that over the last over
the last 20 or so years his comments
have included that Saddam Hussein was
involved in the 1993 World Trade Center
bombing and the Oklahoma City bombing
that Hillary Clinton's aide humi Abaddon
is a secret agent of the Muslim
Brotherhood which was actually repeated
by people like Michele Bachmann who at
the time was a congresswoman he's
promoted the idea that President Barack
Obama is a secret Muslim that General
David Petraeus former director of the
CIA submitted to Sharia law whatever
that means and many other completely
outrageous conspiracy theories and the
vice president of that organization is
now running the staff of the National
Security Council the National Security
Council responsible for some of the most
important decisions our country makes
about keeping Americans safe and I
encourage you go and read about Frank
Gaffney read about the center for
security policy and you're going to
start to understand how this
administration is the administration of
the extremist hate group right so the
the Bush administration we could say was
an administration subjugated and taken
over by neoconservative Warhawk ISM
right the administration of P knack the
project for a new American Century
people like Rumsfeld and Wolfowitz and
John Bolton and Bill Kristol that line
of thought not all of those people
literally connected to P knack but that
line of thought the Trump administration
is the administration of hate groups and
ideological extremists conspiracy
theorists the people like Jerome Corsi
who during the Obama administration were
saying stuff like Michelle Obama's a man
and I don't know John Brennan is a
secret Muslim or whatever it was that
that guy was saying some of them are now
part of the administration and I guess
it's like a case of pick your poison and
we've talked a little bit about how in a
way Trump surrounding himself with the
more buffoonish nuts
maybe prevents him from doing as
destructive foreign policy as george w
bush was doing although i don't know i
mean these people are pretty capable of
doing really bad things yeah i feel like
there are two wings of the trump
administration now one is the crony
corrupt wing who are just in it to
enrich themselves those people like
Jared Kushner and Steve minuchin and
then there's the deplorable wing and
that includes you know formerly Steve
Bannon yep John Bolton and you can
scratch you can put this guy in as one
of the
Horrible's I think absolutely disgusting
that someone like this would have a
position of such consequence in an
administration but alas that this is
what we're dealing with right now and I
I don't actually have any ideas for how
we might combat this other than voting
these people out and voting Trump out in
2020 this isn't the most important story
by any means but it's really really
funny you know how Donald Trump has this
history of lying about crowd sizes the
biggest example is the inauguration of
his presidency his inauguration as
president which didn't have big
attendance and Trump claimed it was
historic then he forced his first press
secretary Sean Spicer to go out and lie
on his first day on the job and say this
was the biggest audience ever and it was
just incredible Trump has done it again
and he's continued to do these campaign
style rallies he did one earlier this
week in Nashville Tennessee and the
crowd sighs that he claimed was bigger
than the configured capacity of the
arena where they did the rally the New
York Times originally said there were a
thousand people at this rally and that
was wrong they eventually corrected it
but obviously the New York Times is
failing and fake so Donald Trump tweeted
tweeted tweeted the failing and corrupt
New York Times estimated the crowd last
night at a thousand people when in fact
it was many times that number and the
arena was rocking this is the way they
demean and disparage they are very
dishonest people who don't get me and
never did now it is true that the
original New York Times article set a
thousand it was later updated to fifty
five hundred the Trump campaign
yesterday said that there were eight
thousand people at the rally before the
rally took place at another event Trump
said there were twelve thousand people
already waiting for him at the rally and
eventually sort of like the final and I
guess most formal number claimed by
Trump is that there were over 8,000
people by his organization there were
over 8,000 people the problem with that
is that the capacity as laid out for the
event on Tuesday according to Bob scone
II who runs the auditorium is that the
maximum capacity was 7,500 to 8,000 so
whether Trump is claiming that there
were over 8,000 people or 12,000 people
it's not possible and we have a picture
by the way of the event it really
doesn't look like a
huge crowd tons of empty seats even just
in this particular area of the arena and
as usual you know I end up Pat with the
question of why bother lying about these
things Ken Trump not help himself does
he think nobody's ultimately going to
check it out
what is the fixation on such irrelevant
things that from day one clearly have
fixated this guy and is it the cult of
personality is it the delusions of
grandeur the narcissism the belief that
nobody's gonna fact-check them or if
they do that he'll just call it fake
news which is what he did when people
fact-checked Sean Spicer on day one of
the administration I don't really get it
he's trying to compensate for what he
lacks I think and what he lacks right
now is high approval numbers they're
around 40% he also talked about the size
of his hands yet again you know this
campaign rally so I think he's trying to
make up for something that he doesn't
have or I mean I'm sure he would say
there's a problem there of course that's
where my mind is going you think that
these claims are the equivalent of the
guy who drives the gigantic monster
truck despite having no practical need
for it maybe as compensation for some
other physical shortcoming that they may
be experiencing yeah that's Trump in a
nutshell I think yeah yeah that maybe
that actually maybe so once again lies
about crowd size I mean why just move on
move on to lies that are more useful to
you right because ultimately who is
really impressed by a crowd of over
8,000 or 12,000 versus 5,500 aren't
people paying attention to other things
now although maybe I'm wrong maybe like
the committed Trump just really does
care about whether there were fifty five
hundred people or eighty five hundred
people I don't know I don't really know
too many the President of the United
States you're supposed to be able to get
a large crowd to attend your rallies why
don't you think I mean ten thousand even
drawing those numbers that should be
easy for him didn't sixty million vote
for the guy like really what difference
does it make whether eighty five hundred
or twelve thousand or five thousand
people went to one one particular rally
we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine to david p here is a
voicemail that is making I don't know a
point I don't I don't want to evaluate
it until we listen to it but it is
making a point about Roseanne bars sort
of explanation not excuse but
explanation for her comments
the sleep medication ambien let's take a
listen to the voicemail no I'm not
defending Roseanne Barr but there has
been some extremely weird things people
have done went on and even like murder
people drive a car have sex in their
sleep
I mean it is certainly possible but it's
still no excuse what she said right I
think that's the point which is there's
no denying that ambien can cause unusual
behavior in people but it's not going to
cause someone who doesn't think racist
things - all of a sudden think racist
things right so if we're going to talk
about ambien as an explanatory factor in
what Roseanne did it would be that it
might have disinhibited her in a way
that she decided to get on Twitter and
tweet the racist things that she already
thinks but the idea you know it's the
Mel Gibson thing right no matter how
much I drink I'm not going to start
using the n-word and saying bad things
about black people because I don't
believe those things no matter how much
ambien I take and I guess that's not
even the right way to say it because you
would who takes extremely high it's just
you either take ambien or you don't it's
pretty binary it's not going to make me
all of a sudden believe things that I
don't believe all of those might be
disinhibited substances but they're not
going to make me all of a sudden think
that Asians are a major problem in
society if it's not something that I
already think and that's I think what is
being missed here and if you know that
ambien lowers your inhibitions and makes
you say wacky crazy things move your
phone away from the bed exactly sign out
of your Twitter account before you take
it I mean there's yeah there's ways
around this nobody's denying ambien can
cause unusual behavior but the idea that
it makes you racist is absolutely
pathetic we've got a great bonus show
for you today we'll talk about the
downfall of rising Republican star
Republican Missouri governor Eric
Greitens we will talk about a woman
caught shaving her legs at a public pool
in Florida and we will also talk about
Walmart's new initiative for all
employees who have been with them 90
days or more
College for a dollar a day as long as
it's one of three online schools and we
will talk about which schools those are
on today's bonus show get access to the
bonus show sign up at join pakman.com or
by becoming a patron at patreon.com
slash david package
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
you